hello there I'm actor Jonathan Lipnicki
and I'm here to wish a Happy Father's
Day to my movie dad Jerry Maguire that's
right I'm the cute little kid who taught
you that the human head weighs 8 pounds
the human head weighs 8 pounds but now I
bench 250 and I'm a competitive
Brazilian jiu-jitsu fighter
here's a picture of me with my shirt off
you're welcome but seriously I'm a
purple belt you don't want to with Jay
lip but enough about me because I'm here
to thank you Jerry McGuire for
everything you did for me from drunkenly
brooding on my mom's couch having a
nervous breakdown
oh wait wait I want to tell you more
about my dad dropping completely
unnecessary f-bombs when I wanted to go
to the zoo what's so takes is you Ray
the suit you know he was closed you
complete me Jerry
sure you weren't my real dad but you
love me anyway
so much so that you hastily married my
mom all because of my overwhelming
cuteness if you don't love her you've
got to tell her kids amazing right my
god
just look at me how could one child be
so ludicrously almost illegally adorable
I mean women would ovulate just from
looking at me from my fluffy hair to my
infectious giggle to my precocious fun
facts you know bees and dog good smell
fear what a little scamp and who can
forget those glasses am i right
certainly not any producer director
casting director in Hollywood because
everybody still thinks of me as a cute
little kid from Jerry Maguire never mind
that I'm a talented classically trained
adult actor capable playing a wide
variety of roles because hey you little
git from Jerry Maguire say show me the
money
deciding my king line you [ __ ] yes I
said it I said but I digress because I'm
here to thank you Jerry Maguire you're
always the most fun guy around sure you
were probably experiencing an episode of
clinical mania but hey it was never a
dull moment with Jerry Maguire flip out
so happy Father's Day Jerry kind of lost
me a Kwan but you had me at hello
and Cameron Crowe if you have any more
parts for me
check out my verify Twitter at Jay
Lipnicki thanks to Jonathan Lipnicki to
see Louis CK's TV daughter Hadley
Delaney tell Louie a thing or two for
Father's Day be sure to click the link
below